الصراع في السودان يتواصل لينذر بتحول
البلاد لبؤره توتر اقليمي وجبهه قتال قد
تمتد لدول الجوار توتر صاحبته دعوات دوليه
واقليميه الى ضروره نزع فتيل الازمه
والالتزام بمسار الهدنه واعاده البلاد
لاكمال المسار الديمقراطي المتعثر منذ
سنوات طويله الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان هذا ما اكده امينه العام انطونيو
غوتيريش الذي دعا الجيش وقوات الدعم
لتغليب لغه الحوار وانهاء الصراع الذي يجب
ان يكون مرتبطا بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار
السودان الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان وستفعل كل ما بوسعها لتوفير
الظروف الامنيه من اجل تقديم الدعم
الانساني للشعب السوداني ومن نيويورك ايضا
اكدت مندوبه بريطانيا في الامم المتحده ان
بلا تهدف للحصول على دعم مجلس الامن
لمقترحات الاتحاد الافريقي فيما يخص الوضع
الحالي في السودان الذي تحول لبقعه
جغرافيه ساخنه
ما نود فعله هو الحصول على الدعم الكامل
من مجلس الامن لمقترحات ايجاد للتقدم نحو
وقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم العوده للعمليه
السياسيه
التطورات الحاصله دفعت باطراف دوليه
واقليميه وعربيه لطرح مبادرات تهدئه بين
الطرفين والتوسط لاتفاق على وقف اطلاق
النار لتعبيد الطريق امام حكومه مدنيه حيث
ان المبعوث الاممي للسودان اشار الى ان
طرفي الصراع في السودان منفتحان على
الحوار الخراب والدمار وفق مراقبين فان
انقاذ البلاد من الفوضى والدمار وتشكيل
حكومه تكنوقراط تضمن الخروج من الازمه
الحاليه يتطلب تجديد الرياده الدبلوماسيه
من طرف المجموعه الدوليه ومعاقبه الاطراف
التي تسببت في زعزعه استقرار السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات